[Music]
so i am going to confess
uh here today yes tell me everything i
have once
tried printing porn at my home uh when i
was a kid
at my parents house i tried printing
porn so that i could
check it off later and keep it in my
room and hide it somewhere right
yeah the problem with that though is i
got so horny that i started jacking off
to porn on the computer and i totally
forgot that i printed out already oh no
i'm done and i'm like i feel good you
know i go upstairs and i go to sleep the
next morning
my parents yep next next morning my
parents come to my room's like
what is this oh
why do parents do that [ __ ] it's like
[ __ ] you know what the [ __ ] it
is it's [ __ ] cut to the chase
tell me how i'm finished they're awkward
too yeah yeah they're like
they're hoping they're hoping for that
one
he's like oh it's a book report yeah yes
just one percent they're hoping it's
something up or maybe they want to see
you oh they're having fun okay
i get it now because honestly i feel
like say like now like if you're a
parent you're like
you go up to your kid and for your kid
you're like holy [ __ ] they're mad they
came like what the [ __ ] is this right
but behind the doors like
dude let's [ __ ] with them that's true
there's a part of it i think we're gonna
do that
i think it depends right like some
parents take it so seriously and they'll
just be like oh my god
our kid is corrupted by the devil oh
yeah suck a dick
right i would like put it on like the
refrigerator door and act like it
yeah oh that's good that's really good
it's hilarious hold it put on my glove
compartment and then let me entice her
to drive him
oh can you give me something in the
glove compartment when he opens it that
picture's right there and i'll just see
what his reaction is
his heart's going to sink i know or be
like embarrass him in front of
oh my god he has like you're going to
take a taika and a girl to the movies
oh hey take it here i found this on uh
on your bed man and just give it to him
are you putting this out it's like a
picture of her with on top of that thank
you
you guys are getting a fight oh [ __ ]
she's gonna fake fight act like it's
bart and then you guys like fake
fighting like oh get the board
oh that's [ __ ] traumatic
i'll wait ten years to do that has taken
gone through like uh
my porn stash no not yet no no no no has
he gone through an experience where like
it's
like heart sank and like was like
mortified
yeah yeah he's only two i don't know two
and a half
um maybe when i go up behind him and i
scare him oh okay
that might be very it's he's pretty
basic they're gonna ask if he's like
playing with himself i'm like i think so
was i boys i thought that that's who
we're gonna ask
i just kept playing with myself pretty
early on too i don't even remember
do you remember the first time you
actually came yeah nothing came out
oh i remember i would try and like
nothing would happen
like people would just tell me like jack
i would feel like i would feel like
coming but nothing would it's dry
heaving
oh because i remember so was your
[ __ ] going i was on the bed i was
watching this like documentary on like
how the golden gate bridge was
built and then i was just like there
because i was like every time i would
just play with it because like nothing
when you see the golden gate bridge
[Laughter]
oh my god you go into his porn stage
it's just [ __ ] buildings
i'm not gonna go through that i ain't
going through san francisco man huh
is this an inside joke i didn't catch on
there's all pictures of [ __ ] posters
of buildings in the golden gate and [ __ ]
imagine though i feel like if because
some people they like [ __ ] cars and
like they yeah
you know door knobs the ferris wheel
yeah
[ __ ] a car inanimate object wait what
did your parents
do like what did they say like what
happened so they never heard the story
to finish the story i i lied that i
don't know what happened there
i think someone hacked our computers
guys they're good old i've
hacked it and they're printing porn and
they're framing me and
never came clean with it back then
because i should i should talk to my
parents about it
no i don't think you have to they know
they know no i think he has to
just kind of like for myself for myself
yeah i just need to like
but back then parents were so naive
about technology true i mean it was
it was kind of believable i guess yeah
because it was how can we go to carrie
how come we went to you
how old were you oh i was uh
i had been like 12 or 13. how come we
didn't blame it on carrie five or six
true yeah do you have a little you
he would have been like that was fine
yeah [ __ ] imagine i wouldn't thought
you talking about that online it's not
my mom
but yeah uh speaking of printing porn
though uh a man by the name of john
hughes let me pull up his picture real
quick he's a big
porn printer huh he went to walmart to
print it
that's tough why don't you buy the
[ __ ] printer dude
i like that this is his mug shot i like
it
this guy saw what he diamond i did it
he's a free man i like that
[ __ ] off prince porn today like
this day and age right what did he bring
in like a
usb or like i don't know they don't
really go into detail as to
what the device was all they said was
that
he's printing porn of walmart and when
invest when when police showed up
because then like the workers were like
okay wait why did the police have to
show up okay long story short i was
trying to like leave this for the last
bit because it gets kind of dark oh no
oh but the reason why his porn printing
caught the attention
uh of of the workers there who then
called the police
was that they suspected that the images
were uh
of cabinets yes under the cabinets under
age cabinets
there's been many stories where like
they they
they take the photos and they print them
out so i guess they distribute them
but they always go and they get caught
by going to places like that oh i don't
know
uh maybe they don't want to do it at
home because they don't want it to be
traced back to their computer
oh actually we have to go online but
someone someone has to handle your
photos
and then you so you have so that's how
they get caught is because someone
literally has to look maybe they think
that people are just like printing it
oh yeah maybe they think there's some
sort of like you know when you go to the
doctor there's like
a physician patient privacy so they
think there's like
there's that with the random minimum
wage at walmart yeah maybe they're like
this is secret i can trust you
when interrogated by the police his
reasoning for
printing out photos at walmart uh was
that he was printing them out for the
homies or locked up
and so he his whole alibi was that i'm
just trying to supply my friends with
some entertainment
oh they suspected it was underage but
they didn't but it's not
yeah well i don't think his his
explanation is true i think
it's as far as himself he's trying to
get away with it or maybe they suspected
that that's why he got arrested
but is he getting charged yeah did he
get charged i don't know actually i mean
he should be charged with some kind of
sex crime because it's public yeah i
think he he is like watching [ __ ]
porn at the library
yeah that's true oh you can't print
porno [ __ ] i don't know about printing
but you can't be watching porn and [ __ ]
in public
well then why do they have those porn
theaters that's that's not public that's
private and you have to be of age to go
in
yeah that's like a strip club you're
paying to get in
but then if you're at a library or like
anywhere
and a kid can walk by and see it so he
needs to print it out the strip club
then
he went to the wrong place he should
have gone to the strip and be like can i
use your office maybe we saw kinkos and
thought kinkies
oh that's true oh i like kinky's way
better
i miss pinkos why do they have to call
it fedex kinkos
because fedex bottom just leave it at
kinko's cool you own it
people that print was like back in the
day they don't really print [ __ ] anymore
like you at the house
and they still remember kinkos yeah like
grandma
can you go to king house and print this
out it's like grandma we gotta
we don't need it printed out we just
look at it in the phone i just like the
whole things of reading
dude they love that [ __ ] like old people
yeah they [ __ ] out they like printed
out and they all you gotta do this [ __ ]
too with the glasses
they gotta wear like this and then they
go
when they when they [ __ ] change the
page they do this [ __ ] thing you
think they they've always done that like
that or even as a child their old age
that's sinking in and
we're all going to be like that when
they do with our iphones like because
your eyesight worsens
when you see like my my entra stuff
looking at their their phones you go
yeah my mom does this thing hold on hold
on talking all this [ __ ] you're gonna be
that person dude i need glasses now
man i knew somebody that was young that
used to look at the [ __ ] phone like
this that's bart
yeah only time i do that now is when i'm
watching our uh
playing that the pool game oh yeah watch
it so you can like hit the
the precision you play like it's a 3d
like
because then there's there's angles and
lines right so you have to look at the
lines of where the
the part that always strips me out is uh
you know like most people are
nearsighted but old people get fart
sided far sides we can't see close yeah
yeah so like when like old people they
look at things
and they gotta like put it further away
oh my [ __ ] i suppose see it
better it was farther away
but i get it that's how their eye is
shaped but it just it's not
intuitive to like oh you want to see it
okay
versus like wait who are you nadine take
a couple steps back ah
it's weird damn so did this guy get
charged with anything yeah so he did get
charged with
a third degree felony for distributing
pornographic material and he's being
held without bail
and i guess they're still trying to
figure out the whole child
exploitation aspect of it like yeah you
could probably still be a sex offender
just by doing that in public though yeah
yeah yeah for sure he's a sex offender
can't you even get
a sex offending kind of thing by peeing
in public too or pooping in public
because it's like indeed
yeah for sure you're even having sex in
public
well that's worse than people you're
really right yeah that's way worse than
people for sure but i'm just like yeah
even that is a sex offending yeah i feel
bad
for the people that like they like being
naked in their own house
and for whatever reasons like the blinds
are opened or whatever and like i guess
you know you assume that like
out during the day at least like
outside's brighter insides dark you
can't really see into the house when
when it's daytime but then for some
reason people still see them and they
get called on you know
the cops called on them and then they
end up being a sex and offender for just
being
really in your own house really i think
there has been a husband
i'm naked all the time yeah like people
leave their door open because they want
to have like that breeze go through
their house so they
they're kind of just like the breeze
between the crotch there we go maybe
from the door to the crotch oh it sounds
like nice
but yeah but then and then like for
those people i feel bad because then
like you know you get you get this sex
offender label now and it takes
years for it to like for you to be taken
off of it oh i guess i'm not going to go
in this
because there's been cases where there's
been guys just jacking off looking
outside the windows
true that's another thing that's
probably what's happening but isn't that
shouldn't that be okay that's not your
house you're inside the house
black people could see you check off oh
yeah people can see you and they're not
other people
like this you're looking out the way if
you're looking out the window and you're
jacking off like this and all they see
in your face
yeah i think that's fine face that's not
illegal you're in your own house now
that shouldn't be fine
he's not speaking he's not speaking
ethics it's unethical i think you're
going ethics and he's just going
logistics
yeah legality logistically too that
shouldn't work out
but it does it's weird because what's
the difference between you actually just
jacking off in your own house in your
own bathroom versus
not in your bathroom something else i'm
finished i'm not looking at the people
outside that could be a kid
i know but you're talking ethics yeah
yeah i'm just talking about what if
someone's staring at a tree and jacking
off
yeah he's in public he's in public he
has to be
hidden no i mean a tree in front of your
house yeah i'm thinking about a guy
going like this to the blinds he's
looking at a tree
sometimes those trees have those like
holes that kind of look like a vagina
what are those trees going to grow [ __ ]
no blank yeah he's all like damn it's
not grown yet i have a tree costume
it's a cactus bar with bart wants to
climb it he's trying to [ __ ] that palm
tree
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can bring around wow yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you